and our shoutout tonight for one of the
great champions of investigative
journalism Tom Galloway who passed away
earlier this year a prominent lawyer he
quietly helped to support journalists
around the world who were committed to
taking truth to power especially in his
beloved Appalachia where he grew up poor
never forgetting those who remain
trapped in a place where powerful
interests oppress and abuse
it was a project that no one news
organization had been able to take on a
sweeping indictment of how and why so
many people in America's Appalachian
region had no safe reliable source of
clean drinking water reporters from
three different outlets came together
for the project from the Charleston
Gazette mail my name is Katie Coyne I'm
a reporter of the Charleston Gazette now
West Virginia Public Broadcasting I'm
Molly born I work with West Virginia
Public Broadcasting and the Lexington
herald-leader my name is Will Wright I
work for the Lexington herald-leader
this project especially dives into
things that affect people's daily life
you know access to water it's something
that many people don't even think about
spending months traveling across West
Virginia and Kentucky water should be
clear and odorless
and that's something we don't have here
and happen for a very long time
if you turn on your tab and it's white
and it's no like pouring you know that's
not good it was a journalistic tour de
force all made possible by one wealthy
lawyer whose only credit was a short
screen credit at the end of the video
embellishing the Galloway foundation
chaired by Tom Galloway who died earlier
this year I think he really understood
poverty I think he understood some of
the really intense struggles that happen
in places like where he grew up in
Appalachia and he had a very deep sense
of wanting to give back Shawnee Senate
runs the ground truth project that
spearheaded the water investigations Tom
understood the power of journalism from
his very earliest days as a lawyer where
he took on big coal and really went
after some of the companies that were
really destroying the environment and
treating people very unfairly in the
communities they where they were based
as a successful lawyer Galloway was
later involved in going after the
misty's at the corrupt energy company
Enron he funded projects about human
rights and LGBT rights in Africa he
followed up on the reporting that Rhonda
Schwartz and I did at ABC News about the
treatment of garment factory workers in
sweatshops in the American territory of
the northern marianas locked fire exits
overheated electrical panels toilets
that don't work what authorities called
flagrant violations of US labor and
safety laws part of a legal team that
later got a 20 million dollar settlement
for some 30,000 workers but Galloway's
passion was for Appalachia where he grew
up in poverty and then first emerged as
a lawyer speaking up for the little guy
Tom really dedicated his entire career
to trying to help those people who are
underserved telling their story became
part of that work journalism became a
critical appendage to all of the legal
work that he did in a way that
tell a story that he wouldn't
necessarily be able to tell in the
courtroom Galloway's Becky has already
helped to fund major investigations at
West Virginia's leading newspaper The
Gazette mail and a time the paper was in
financial straits
according to reporter Ken ward Tom
Galloway's legacy for Appalachia is not
just all the litigation he did to bring
bad guys to justice but it's the
journalism that's going to live on for
years and years and years giving people
the kind of information they need about
their community we have two reporters in
our newsroom now that are funded by them
and at a time when advertising revenues
are dropping and it's difficult to keep
staff up that kind of those kind of
resources two additional reporters one
of them dedicated to covering southern
West Virginia and the other one
dedicated to covering poverty issues in
Galloway was once named trial lawyer of
the year by a group called public
justice and he lived in a life of luxury
with grand homes in Colorado Washington
DC and Martha's Vineyard but his wife
Kathy says he would have traded it all
to be one of those investigative
reporters he admired so much I think he
was so enamored of the work that you
were able to do Brian and Rhonda who
would have given his left pinkie to be
able to have hospitality you've had a
journalism do you still drink your tap
water or is this solely what you drink
not really why not the water project
from ground truth came as Galloway knew
his days might be numbered and he died
know that word Galloway fellows across
Appalachia and elsewhere doing the work
he dreams of having a strong
investigative journalism Yoona in every
newspaper and radio station across
America he was a brilliant storyteller
and he would like to see those brilliant
storytellers telling the public what's
happening in their communities across
the country but that would that would be
a wish come true for him
[Music]
Tom Galloway was a strong supporter and
a good friend to me and our executive
producer Rhonda Schwarz and to so many
journalists around the world he will be
missed but his legacy will continue to
the Galloway foundation in the evil
hands of his wife Cathy and daughter
Erin that's our program for tonight
thanks so much for joining us we'll see
you right back here next week on the law
and crime Network
you